the principal of east side community
school in new york
sent out a graphic to his uh community
detailing the eight types of whiteness
this the scale
shows white identities ranging from good
white identities
to bad white identities but even that
is a little bit of a misnomer because
the premise of the scale
is that white people are bad being white
just
being a white guy which by the way
the principle is is defining the left is
defining
sometimes the left wants to say hey
there's no such thing as whiteness
come on whiteness is a social construct
well
whiteness is not particularly important
to my identity i don't think of myself
primarily as white
think of myself catholic you know
american new yorker
at least originally now tennessee and i
think of all these
uh conservative whatever
but the left seems to know what white
means
the left seems to be able to identify
who white people are and the left is
calling for the abolition
of white people and for for social
disadvantage for them but he says
the the good white people are so-called
white abolitionists abolitionists and
the bad white people are
white supremacists so the eight
categories start with the worst one
that's a white supremacist
who's a white supremacist i don't know i
don't really see very many of them but
i'm told that
75 million americans are white
supremacists then there's a white
voyeurism what is white voyeurism
i know that sounds kind of kinky i don't
know i don't know what white voice is
then there's white privilege
notice by the way it's shifting
obviously whoever put this
graphic together is not not the most
literate person in the world you go
you have white supremacist then you get
an ism
then you get a privilege white privilege
then you get
white benefit i guess that's where you
you know it's
like you get certain advantages from
being white
like having to listen to these idiots
tell you how evil you are then there's
white confessional
so you it's like i guess the early
stages of white guilt
then there's a white critical that's
where you sort of don't like yourself
because of your skin color then there's
white traitor
so i guess that's just what it sounds
like and then there's white
abolitionist abolitionist
you want to abolish white people
you know it's it's funny because when
the the racial identitarians on the on
the right
you know called whatever you want to
call them white supremacist
white neo this or that
when they say in their you know sort of
most fevered
uh protestations they'll say the left
is anti-white they want to abolish white
i don't know about peop but then these
guys come out and they say that very
thing they say yeah we want to abolish
white people
what what do they think is going to
happen here
there was a pew research survey i've
mentioned it on the show a few times
that measured racial consciousness uh
you know how important race is to one
sense of identity
and it found out that race is very
important to the identity
of uh black people hispanic people and
asian people in america
you just measure or you say do you think
race is important are very important to
you and it's something like greater than
50
of those groups said yes it is number
for white people was 15
white people broadly speaking do not
have this racial consciousness it's
ironic because we are told by
the left that white people are the only
people who can be racist
what does racism mean i guess racism is
i think of racism
it is a hatred and animosity for people
on the basis of their race
which is which is wrong because racism
is an affront to human dignity
but the way the left defines racism it's
sort of like
it's completely divorced from reality
because racism is apparently only held
by people
who have statistically speaking the
least racial consciousness of anybody in
the country
what do you think the end game of this
is because what i what i would like what
i think would be lead to a nice
flourishing society
is if people didn't think primarily
about race i mean
you know to some degree you think about
race i'm i'm descended from italian
people
i eat a lot of pasta obviously i speak
with my hands i'm doing that right now
so i'm not saying there's no such thing
as race or something like that
but race has its proper place
right i don't i don't lead marches i'm
not a spaghetti supremacist or something
like that
when you when you make an idol out of
the out of race you get racism
very bad the state has a proper place in
our lives when you make an idol out of
the state you get statism
uh individuality or this our senses
individuals
has its proper place in a politicality
when you make an idol out of that you
got hyper individualism society starts
to break down so you don't you don't
want to
make an idol out of these things you
want to utterly deny them either
but what the left is telling us is that
race is
basically the most important thing we
should make an idol out of it we should
pursue a racist
policy and we're going to castigate
people who have basically very little
racial identity on the basis of their
race
all that can do the only thing that will
happen from that is to increase racial
identity
and division maybe that's what the left
wants i assume it is
but this isn't just happening at some
kooky school in new york
but you know this you've seen this kind
of stuff in corporate boardrooms you've
seen this kind of stuff in a lot of psas
we do the work commercials on my youtube
channel
where you don't even know what product
these companies are selling they're just
selling
racial grievance or sexual grievance but
you see this
all around the country notably at a
school in philadelphia
that is honoring black communism
this there is a school in philadelphia
that is honoring black communism
and black power this comes to us by way
of christopher ruffo at city journal
who's covering critical race theory so
this a teacher at a school william d
kelly school in pennsylvania
is leading 10 and 11 year old students
into the school auditorium to simulate a
black
power rally to free angela davis
a communist terrorist from prison
because she was once held in prison
awaiting uh trial on charges of
conspiracy
kidnapping and murder and and they the
teacher in
in philly had the students walk around
with signs that read black power
jail trump a little anachronistic given
when angela davis was on trial
free angela and black power matters
they chanted the uh about africa they
chanted about ancestral power
then free angela free angela
angela davis now when i say she's a
communist i mean she was an actual
member of the communist party
and won the international uh lenin peace
prize
ironically named just given out by the
soviet union i mean
this woman is a hard core communist
terrorist this is the curriculum being
taught at william d kelly school now
you're going to be shocked to hear this
hold a sit down to hear this william d
kelly school one of the worst performing
schools in pennsylvania
i know i know you would have thought
with a with such a brilliant curriculum
such as this
that these would be the most urbane
educated uh graduates
anywhere in pennsylvania right no
william d kelly school has just three
percent proficiency in math by sixth
grade
nine percent proficient in reading by
graduation only thirteen percent
of uh students who graduate from the
school will have achieved
basic literacy now obviously
this school should be shut down not
serving students at all
probably destroying these students lives
by utterly failing them on education
filling their heads with a bunch of
stupid and evil ideas
are conservatives willing to say that
because this is a
radical agenda that is
being pushed probably the school doesn't
want to educate the children
because educated students would
understand what bunk all of this is
much better for for these political
radicals to keep everybody stupid and
uneducated
much more likely that people will be
compliant that way
but i think a lot of conservatives don't
want to touch this stuff because
conservatives don't want to be called
racist
now i know what you're thinking you're
thinking wait a second these people on
the right
or on the left rather they're the ones
pushing
racism the people on the right are
opposing racism i know
but but because of that conservatives
are so touchy about this sort of thing
they don't want to be accused of any
mean term especially because of the
extraordinary prominence of of racism
you know
in canceling people right this term
racism that they just don't want to
touch it
the only way that we're going to be able
to retake the culture
is by speaking plainly about these
things
people should not be given special
privileges because of their race
based on claims of historical grievance
or this sort of wicked ideology
communism whatever you know students
should not be participating in
three angela davis reenactments
students should not be taught that
communism is a good thing
you might be able to hear my newborn son
crying in the background right now as i
as i record from home and he obviously
is in
great agreement that society is in
turmoil and we have to do
something about it we need to be able to
clearly state we believe this we don't
believe this
not just hey we're going to be inclusive
and yeah we can teach critical race
theory but we should also maybe teach
shakespeare or something no we need to
be much more
serious about this we need to be
exclusive about this we need to say
this trash does not belong in schools
teachers who teach this sort of thing
critical race theory this teacher
whoever did the
angela davis thing that teacher needs to
be fired that teacher
probably should never be hired again by
any school that teacher should be
ostracized from his community
this sort of thing should if this does
show up at a school
the administrators of that school should
probably be fired they should at least
be deeply ashamed
we should we should say enough is enough
we're going to teach good things
that will form students brains in the
right way
that will teach them how to read and
write how to think
that we'll teach them to have a an
ordered view of the good
that will teach them virtue that will
teach them not to do vice not to engage
in vice
and to to shun all those sorts of wicked
things
the currently open uh sort of um
subjectivist relativistic kind of
tone that we have on the right it ain't
gonna work new york post is reporting
more schools are ditching shakespeare
remember i was
talking about this years ago when yale
started minimizing the role of
shakespeare in the english department
people said oh it's not a big deal come
on michael they're making the curriculum
a little more inclusive no they're not
they're not
what the left is doing is taking out
the old good books and replacing them
with new
bad books and they're justifying this on
their stupid racial theories
which are not only dumb but also
wrong and evil ayanna thompson who's an
english professor at arizona state
university
said in an interview that shakespeare
was a tool
used to civilize black and brown people
in england's empire and therefore we got
to get rid of it
she's half right the thing is
shakespeare is a tool
to civilize all of us and is my i don't
know if i'm brown or something i'm
swarthy i'm sicilian
are we brown i don't know are we white i
don't know maybe a a sort of
uh maybe i'll be able to to escape the
worst uh
worst consequences of the new racial
regime the left is pushing just i'm a
little sworthy probably not though i
think they're actually going to go after
me especially
on the basis of my views shakespeare
civilizes all of us shakespeare teaches
us about
human nature teaches us about who we are
teaches us how to make sense of our
freedom how to make sense of our worst
impulses how to make sense
of the places that we live in what the
leftist pushing is a sort of scientific
view they're saying there's no such
thing as human nature
different peoples are different
different races are different and by the
way it's all subjective and it's all
just words words words as
hamlet would say the left would know
that if they uh
were not so illiterate practically
illiterate and then culturally
illiterate too
what the right is pushing what
conservatives advocate is a much more
serious scientific view
meaning there is objective reality there
is such a thing as human nature we all
share that human nature and we need to
come
to understand that that is science too
that is a much more serious scientific
perspective the recognition of human
nature
and a politics that acknowledges human
nature that's much more serious than uh
whatever the sort of random covid
reopening policies
or the dire threats of global warming i
think that
the the attacks on human nature that are
being done attacks on our educational
system
a far greater threat or far greater
threat than global warming or anything
else
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you